[Music]
is there any specific moment shooting
this film that you said I can't believe
how stunt work is done today on dark
fate compared to t2 well to the better
and for the better and for the worse
how does well there were more stunt
women I really got a little crazy trying
to micromanage because I mean to every
detail like she can't be the back of me
cuz her wig needs cutting like I'm not
gonna give one moment away that doesn't
seem real so like okay you have to be on
a wire here and go down this hill and we
could have debbie do it cuz it's just
the back of you and I'm like nope Debbie
needs her hair cut like you know I'm
like I'll do it
and I didn't do it that well but you
know what I mean I just you don't want
that one second that's gonna break the
audience concentration or then there
would be the stunt girl from Hungary
that they had hired and that's a whole
different school old school of stunts
where you know and the girl is doing
good work but it's real old school so
she's in a car accident she's flinging
herself around cuz selling it and I'm
like no no Sarah Connor does not thrash
like yes you sell it but you don't look
like you're an out-of-control rag doll
cuz this is Sarah Connor like you know
it's so hard to not get in there and
it's not so much that I'm a control
freak but more like I just I Oh Sarah
Connor the dignity I don't want to
disappoint her you know so this was the
one film that I've done where I was kind
of that person I was protective of every
moment and I couldn't be there because
it's a larger film and they're off in
Spain doing little stuff and you know I
it just it was it was really hard
[Music]